welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Ashish Cole who was at Yale as Singh
postdoctoral associate in South Asian
Studies her work focuses on caste Islam
and politics in South Asia with law and
gender as components within that
framework today we'll talk with
Professor Cole about her essay making
new Muslim arraign reform and social
mobility and colonial Punjab 1890s to
1910s welcome professor Cole Thank You
Marilyn for having me here
sure let us begin with the paper that
you recently wrote tell us about it well
the people is about the Orion community
of colonial Punjab mostly the early 20th
century from the 1890s to the 1940s as
you said now arise were a largely
agricultural Muslim caste in in colonial
Punjab who were classified by colonial
law as agriculturalists that basically
meant that they were not at least in the
eyes of the state that they were not
commercial or an artisanal costs but
caste that derived its livelihood mostly
from agriculture and land ownership in
one form or another so they were about 8
percent of the population in
turn-of-the-century Punjab during the
19th century Punjab and but I'm mostly
concentrated in the central districts of
Amritsar Jolanda Lahore and Ambala okay
so the people talks about this new
attempt by some education English
educated urban and reform-minded Orien
elite in the early 20th century to come
up with a new sort of history for their
identity now this was partly in response
to colonial characterizations of the
arise as good farmers who were really
industrious but were also in terms of
land in terms of size of land ownership
sort of in a middling status so there
were these other groups called Jarts and
Rajput who were above them who were big
landlords and then there were the Norn
land owning communities like
that is leather workers or porters and
other service providing communities who
were sort of all grouped together into
this homogenous category called the
Camino costs okay so the arise in the
early 20th century and this is what the
paper focuses on sort of start off a
project of sort of writing their own
history and part of that project is
sponsoring the production of a history
called salamu Tiwari which literally
means a sound history there's a longer
title but I'll spare you that which then
is which the so the history this is
published in 1919 it sort of argues that
the arise rather than being these middle
rank small-time vegetable selling and
small-scale farmers of indigenous origin
which is what the colonial state claimed
and they were in their own sort of
colonial ethnographies now this oral
history which position by this person
called maulvi muhammad Akbar Ali Sufi
Jalan very argued that instead of being
these small-time low status farmers
arise were actually of illustrious Arab
Muslim descent and he traced this
genealogy all the way back to the two
early Islamic Arabia in the seventh
century not claiming descent from the
Prophet which was significant in its
time in place but but but still sort of
carving out coming out a unique sort of
genealogy that went all the way back to
early Islamic Arabia without actually
claiming descent from the cross right
okay the important génial of
genealogical event in the senior in this
sort of claim was the early 8th century
Muslim conquest of sync conducted by and
by a Muslim general called Muhammad bin
Qasim and Ja Landry argued that theorize
in colonial Punjab where descendants of
Muhammad bin Qasim Syrian generals so
the glory that the genealogy brought in
terms of being in terms of the an
association with the bringing of Islam
to the subcontinent was what he was
basically after in sort of producing
this genealogical self imagination and
then the Arabs in EOG then sort of
facilitated bv interpretation of some
reformist islamic troops and then it and
then it sort of and then that so the
combined with the genealogy and the and
the and this adapted reformist program
Jerry then claimed that arise were
actually Allah you know these high
status Muslims of pure Arab Muslim
descent
whose practice social religious
practices things like endogamy and
practices of immense seclusion were
derived from the Quran itself and in
saying that he was distinguishing the
arise as much from high status Muslims
high caste or high status Muslims as
from lower status communities like the
leather workers that I mentioned earlier
so this was an attempt to generate a new
history and a new sort of bounded
community grounded in this notion of
both noble birth and ideal sort of
Islamic fighting okay and what led you
to write this paper well this paper
comes out of my dissertation project so
while writing my dissertation I was this
is one of the chapters that I that it
sort of is the beginning of the project
but it's it's kind of chapter two in the
dissertation and while I was writing the
chapter I realized that the implications
of this specific part there are the
scholarly implications of this specific
sort of attempt at at redefining you
know self redefinition in a colonial
context had sort of had profound
implications for scholarly literature on
both reformist Islam in South Asia and
also the sort of scholarly
understandings of how lowest status
communities achieve upward mobility in
early 20th century South Asia so then
sort of that led me to decide that maybe
this can turn into a good journalist a
which can which has a strong narrative
component but at the same time also has
these important analytical arguments to
put forward okay I am curious to know
who Jolla Han Dre and am I saying that
Colin that angel and Ray who was he and
he just decided I'm going to take this
issue on and and basically rewrite
history is what it's sounding like well
yes you're right
and and no so it wasn't as if this this
is some isolated person in one corner of
you know the universe trying to write
like this okay so so the way it happened
was that in the late 19th century
colonial ethnographers you know some of
the most famous ones are Charles Tupper
and Denzel Ibbetson they started
producing these ethnographies of the
subject populations and the whole
project was of
so you know this is this is this is
colonial knowledge production which is a
deeply political project where you do
not want to know the subject population
you know it's not knowledge for the sake
of knowledge it is knowledge for the
sake of the policy development so there
is a sort of a profound political reason
why those histories get produced about
who these subject populations are where
do they come from
the primary motivation for the late 19th
century Punjabi ethnography project was
to identify who owned land and and once
you identify that you know you can
identify potential revenue wares but
then it's not enough to know who owns
land it's also important to know where
land will go once the current owner is
no longer in the picture so that leads
colonialist not refers to ask questions
about inheritance patterns and then
which then is directly linked to Indore
to patterns of marriages because as long
as you have to know who will gets to
marry whom in order to understand who
gets to inherit what and this is the
prod these are the projects that are
sort of developing in the late 19th
century the 1870s 80s and 90s and the
irani community now by this time you
know a Punjabi Muslims were getting well
had been enrolling in in government
colleges and getting what was called
English education at the time so some of
the prominent early leaders at the time
some of them were lawyers who had
trained in England they had come back
and they were really concerned there was
this anxiety about the kind of history
and identities that colonial
ethnographies were producing so out of
that anxiety out of this desire for
quote-unquote correcting the colonial
perception of us you know of our
communities came up multiple attempts at
producing community histories of their
own that whose primary reason was to
counter colonial perceptions of the
community so you see this trend among
other Punjabi communities like charts
and then also sort of coat ominously
there are like you know community-based
organizations associations come up and
that happens also in the case of arise
so so now these are these like a bunch
of these align around lawyers and
politicians and urban your sort of
Valley influential men get together and
say that we have to do something about
the way the colonial gazetteers and all
these colonial texts are portraying us
so so it so happens that they
end up almost appointing Joe Landry to
write this history and he starts doing
the research for it in 1890s and he
doesn't do it all like as like I said in
a sort of sitting by himself in a corner
he actually engages influential and
well-known members of the Irani
community by writing letters to them so
he writes these letters and says here is
a list of 35 questions about the
community that I would like to have your
answers to and then that sort of intra
like intra community at nog rafi then
informs the kind of detail about the
community that he puts into his book so
the production of this history then is
sort of sponsored by self conscious
educated elites of the community and
then this man who was appointed who
claims to be an Orion in the book
himself and before I don't I who do I
have no reason to not believe him at
this point but you never know things can
change right so he almost gets appointed
and then once his book his book the
publication of the book is delayed
because of the First World War
shortage of paper and ink in in in South
Asia and then once it is published a
year later the Orion Association of
India sort of officially recognizes him
as historian of the community and and
says that this book is our official
history so that's how it sort of comes
about and he gets appointed and he's a
Valon author by that time he's written
books about Islam and about Arabia and
about ideas of seclusion and also has
composed a commentary on the Quran okay
so it's sort of this weird ethnography
part very conscious project of history
of production of history right and I'm
curious how you did the research word
and were you able to see his
correspondence with the leaders of that
community so so the so I started out on
this project with a very different idea
but then as I did more research in India
and written about it I came across this
book this little it is a book like it's
Salima tava rake he's an older text and
once I sort of had a chance to peruse it
I had seen references to it and other
audio texts of the period but I sort of
the first time I laid my eyes on it was
in the spring of 2014 so I saw the book
and I realized that something
interesting something really unfamiliar
was
on here both in terms of his approach
towards what a good pious Muslim looked
like and also in terms of his approach
towards how awry community should sort
of rejuvenate itself and claim a high
higher social status in colonial Punjab
for itself what were his ideas and for
both of those so so in terms of social
mobility what he did what he does is a
little is unique because he doesn't take
the well-worn and very familiar sort of
track of claiming descent from the
Prophet or his family or his CIM or the
other companions of the Prophet
basically the contemporaries of the
Prophet which is of more common
genealogical mode of self imagination in
in in South Asia you have other
communities like Ansari's and also the
cities in western India who claim
descent from different companions of the
Prophet now he doesn't do that he claims
descent again like I said from someone
called Sheikh Salim Arai who he claims
was mmm was was someone who migrated to
Syria and then his descendants were
enrolled into Muhammad bin Qasim army
and then ended up coming to Sindh as
conquerors so the so the point of that
genealogy then is to claim that not only
do RI ancestors have Arab blood but they
also have something else which is they
were righteous Muslims who participated
in in the spread of Islam to the
subcontinent
now if within the regional limits or
South Asia the this event this early 8th
century Muslim conquest of Sindh is a
very well remembered through medieval
chronicles and it's sort of marked as
this paradigmatic event like this is the
event this is the event of Islam's
origins in South Asia so it's recognized
as this event and then when a community
in early 20th century Punjab tries to
connect itself in genealogical terms
with that event it's sort of it's a way
to claim sort of the the owner that
comes from not just blood you know like
birth his idea and you know John 3:6
thus and that in his work that birth is
an is a mere accident that is not going
to that alone is not going to give you
such crucial status you must earn this
status by sort of correcting your
conduct and and claiming these ancestors
who
sort of brought Islam to the
sub-continent who wear these righteous
warriors then brings the in that element
of ideal Islamic conduct and pie T so
then the combination of the two then is
what makes his representation of
colonial arise a direct refutation of
colonial ideas about the community and
what conduct specifically right it's
what I'm interested in so it's it's a
the the notion of ideal Islamic conduct
in Jalandhar ease writing is complex but
I'm just going to sort of break it down
here okay very quickly so there are
different aspects to it the most
important is the intellectual aspect
which is about which basically concerns
about the ideal ri man or woman's
approach towards education and learning
so he sort of incurred not only does he
sort of encourage arise to learn about
their religion but also in the or but
also have an open mind towards things
like English education which you know
about 30 to 40 years before before Jalan
theories time was not very popular among
amongst Muslims you know most sort of
aristocratic and high status Muslim
families did not really want their
children going to English sort of
English medium or any government
institutional institutions of Education
so here so that so the idea that we
arise because they are they have this
Arab blood have this predilection for
pursuit for intellectual pursuits they
are they sent there they make sure that
their children learn the Quran there's a
mosque in every village so you know
those kinds of details come in in order
to shore up the notion that this that
that the intellectual aspect is sort of
present among the arise but also needs
to be promoted the second aspect is
about social ideal social and religious
conduct so in addition to saying things
like because we are of Arab descent we
practice caste and Dogma because we want
to protect the purity of our bloodlines
so to speak so in addition to claims
like that he said he also sort of
exhausts fellow their colonial orion's
to make sure that they all their
marriages are in dogmas and also I the
idea that vidoes that arrive eros were
allowed to remarry which was not
something high caste Punjabi Muslims
it's that's something that the high
caste high caste Muslims everywhere and
Hindus also frowned upon
so it's a simultaneous attempt to
distinguish RI intellectual and social
religious practices from those of high
caste and lower cost Muslims and the
final aspect then is economic which is
also very important for him because for
him then that the economic aspect means
both earning an honest living
so not sort of living off of an income
let's say like rent where you don't work
for a life or for your for your money
for money but you let your ancestral
wealth sort of take care of you and your
children so that is not ideal and that
is where the criticism of that is well
Al Andalus criticism of high caste
landlords comes in so he's like this is
not what you want to do you want to make
an honest living because that is what
the Prophet Mohammed asked all believers
to do and then also the flipside of that
is to also pursue ideal spending habits
where you don't spend too much on lavish
weddings and festivities but sort of
maintain this pure and almost ascetic
lifestyle in sort of imitation of the
Prophet Muhammad himself so these
specific aspects that he sort of points
to exemplary arise who already do this
but then also such that the rest of you
also need to sort of follow this these
so I'm curious to know how this
rewriting or revisionist history was
received by everyone else was there any
pushback was the genealogy ever
challenged for instance well so oh look
there is it's it's it's not not
obviously difficult to track the
reception of texts like that's most
often because well I know that you know
the thousand copies of the of Jolanda
Rhys book we're public we're sort of
produced in 1919 but I don't know where
I mean I kind of know where two out of
those copies are at the moment but I
don't know about the rest so he in his
own time there was some pushback so
there was another history of the arise
produced in 1922 which basically claimed
that the arise where of indigenous
descent like all other Muslims in South
Asia and this whole idea of Arab descent
could not be proved either way so a
response to the best of my knowledge
there was like not much response from
within the community within the colonial
period in the 1930s and 40s some
military hand will
do show evidence of so no they so the
there were these military handbooks
would have produced for British officers
so and they would have these short
little introductions to each community
from which the soldiers in the army were
recruited and orion's were one community
and the descriptions in those handbooks
would say the you know sort of orion's
they are descended from Muhammad bin
Qasim and Syrian soldiers you know
that's the kind of evidence that I've
seen in terms of reception so the store
there so this origin stories origin
narrative seems to have calculated into
the official colonial sort of
understanding of these people but but
the response from within the community
then is post-colonial so there was
another history of arise produced in 1st
1963 which is now on its fifth edition
in Pakistan and is continuously printed
and reprinted the most recent edition is
from 1989 and it sort of again makes the
same claim written by somebody else
called Ali Asghar chaudhary makes the
same claim that orion's of are of Arab
descent but takes issue with the
specific genealogical nodes of jail and
varies sort of texts and says that I you
know Ali Asghar allottee for instance
says that I have found no evidence of
this person called Sheikh Salim awry and
in fact the erai ancestors did not come
from Syria they actually came from Banu
umayyah which is the first Islamic
caliphate the dynasty alright this is
fascinating so are is there a story
written for all of the different levels
in the caste system Oh in terms of you
know so there's this story that
jalan-jalan that he wrote for the Aryans
and then it's subsequently been updated
so to speak are there other groups in
the caste system that also have stories
oh yeah I mean absolutely in the Punjabi
so gastrin Punjab is a different sort of
animal than in the rest of India it's
cast crosses religious lines in in South
Asia so then I know that the common
notion is that caste is a Hindu
phenomenon but I think part of my
research is to show that it actually
isn't in that it is particularly
insidious because it persists despite
conversions and it crosses these
religious lines so that you have high
cost and low caste communities in all
religious in all religions in South Asia
and in Punjab the hike
groups like Rajputs and Jats they have
their own genealogy zinf' like us i mean
i think i said it before that the
genealogical mode of imagining your
identity is not new in south asia so in
sort of adopting that way in sort of
adopting that method Germany was
actually following the example of a lot
of other communities around him and also
beef much before him centuries before
him so in addition so for instance royal
genealogies would be produced very
actively produced where these particular
experts in genealogy would be recruited
to write the genealogy of the of the
royal household
similarly sufi genealogies of you know
the sufi scenes their genealogies would
be meticulously recorded high caste
muslims muslims who claimed descent from
the prophet's family have meticulously
recorded genealogies going all the way
back to the prophet's family sometimes
to his daughter sometimes to his
children so those are the meticulously
reported sort of you know like ancestry
but for genealogy although the mode of
imagination is similar to that he adopts
the same method the specific sort of
people that he identifies as ancestors
you know it's it's the track that he
takes that is unique so he doesn't so in
rather than saying that oh we are also
descended from the Prophet which is the
usual way of South Asian Muslims
claiming high caste or high status he
actually doesn't claim that he distances
they arise from science and says we are
not like those ayats those ayats they
don't they don't do anything they don't
have an occupation and we are the kind
of Muslims who follow the Prophet in
pursuing and honest living and we
believe in honest labor and we do not
think that manual labor which is what
cultivating the land would be is sort of
denigrating at all in fact the Prophet
Muhammad himself told one of his Paulo
followers that the only way to alleviate
your problem poverty is to work your way
through it
so you know so there's this active
attempt at I mean fabricating this
genealogy but then also each node each
node that is chosen has a purpose it
sort of reflects a certain value so the
notion of honest economic labor would
distance theorise from high caste Muslim
landlords who don't really work for a
living and look down upon those who
engage in manual labor and then the
ideal source
religious conduct but again this
distinguished theorize from high caste
landlords whose culture is very
different and who in this time and age
in the in the 19th 19th or 20th century
context are not associated with Islamic
fighty and then it at the same time it
four distinct it will differentiate
theorized from lower caste communities
whose religious imagination is very
different yeah so let's talk about how
your research is kind of unique in terms
of this essay from other I see from
other work that is out there today
right so the essay makes two sort of
broad big interventions the first is in
the reformist Lindell so excuse me
there's literature on social mobility
among South Asian Muslims so the
standard sort of way of understanding
how lower status Muslim communities
achieve upward mobility is there's the
sociological model called Ashraf ization
we according to which lower status
Muslims will first imitate the social
religious practices of higher status
Muslims and then over several
generations eventually will also claim
the name of a higher status community so
in the Punjabi context it would mean if
we were to take of the orions as an
example it would mean that your I that
this one Orien community in this one
village identify where the charts are
the dominant community over time start
imitating social religious practices of
juts the most common one being seclusion
of women and then over three or four
generations then you know sort of start
calling themselves charts so they arise
then over the course of this gradual
process become charts so to speak right
now my argument is that Jalan theory is
a sort of vision or his sort of argument
for awry identity is completely
different from this so although he
relies on dissent and notions of on both
descent and religious practices the
track he takes is not Ashraf ization
primarily because he does not actually
claim descent either from the for profit
which is one way he could have gone
towards science and he doesn't claim
that the eyes are actually charts he
doesn't claim that for him our eyes have
a specific genealogy which in which
within itself contains all the elements
of high status
the only thing colonial or
need to do is to remember it because
they have sort of forgotten it after
centuries of sort of habitation in South
Asia I made all these other different
religious communities so the note so the
idea there then is to not become charts
or science but to remain arise but to
recalibrate what the RI name then means
by arguing for this Arab genealogy and
also all this ideal sort of Islamic
piety that it sort of attributes to to
arise who are of Arab stock so because
you have Arab stock
therefore you are innately sort of
inclined towards true Islamic piety so
that's one so it's a very different
model of upward mobility in the in this
context and the other contribution is on
this on the only on understandings of
what reformist Islam means to Muslims
who practice it so the notion of
reformist islam the central idea is that
the islam as practiced by 20th century
muslims is sort of corrupted and and it
has too many on islamic or non islamic
cultural accretions which are usually
labeled custom and the performace
project then is to get rid of all those
on Islamic practices and ideas and go
back to an ideal Islam of the prophetic
age so now the most of the scholarly
literature on reformist Islam among
South Asian Muslims sort of has this I
mean it's a vast and varied literature
but it has this sort of predominant
inclination towards reformers their
ideas and their institutions so we hear
a lot about Salem Han ashraf ali Tanabe
saith immediately all these different
sort of strands of reformist islam and
it and that literature rightfully
emphasizes that that reformism is a
spectrum and there can that there is a
singer theme of khan who is not a
traditionally trained theologian but
it's still a reformist thinker and there
is someone called mawlana ashraf ali
autonomy who is a reform minded
theologian was the traditionally trained
so that is definitely a spectrum and I
think that that literature has done that
work and that is why I'm able to sort of
me take the next step and ought to
mention the gendered politics of Rome
beautiful mister Islam but my contention
is that that the Irani story allows us
move away from the institutional and the
ideological focus and actually look at
some provincial reform minded elites who
are who are interested as much in the
tropes of reformist Islam in the motifs
of reformist as long as they are in
pragmatic sort of methodologies for its
implementation so this is the instance
of the community which is trying to
adapt ideal the ideals and the sort of
the common tropes of reformist islam
like for instance how are Muslim women
to maintain their chastity or what is
the ideal way what is the ideal
education for a good Muslim so so that
is the idea there are other reformers
who are constantly sort of trying to
teach the deep south asian muslims how
to be a good Muslim so there is an
element of that didacticism in john 3 as
well but the sort of the majority of
this text is concerned with actually
thinking about who the arize are they
are peasants and farmers and landowners
and how they are going to implement
these troops in their own lives so if we
are thinking about the seclusion of
women for instance now it's easy for a
high caste Muslim family to settle roots
women because it doesn't need the women
to be part of the labor force but for a
knife farmer who has only a little bit
of land on the outskirts of Lahore he
probably needs his wife working in the
fields and then maybe selling whatever
produce which would very often be
vegetable vegetables and them going and
selling it outwards so how do you adapt
the notion of female chastity the
reformist notion of female chastity to
suit an arrived farmer and his wife so
that is where challenge theory I think
offers an example of was a very
important departure in the way we
conceptualized reformist Islam that not
only is it about people not only is it
about didacticism and pedagogy it is
also about implementation so I think
that that is where my essay is trying to
make an intervention ok this has been
fascinating thank you so much for being
here with us today thank you so much for
having me for more information about
professor Cole and her work please visit
our website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and
area studies at Yale
[Music]